we're learning of new deaths in the
nationwide public health crisis tied to
vaping health officials in Florida and
Georgia confirmed the first deaths in
those states this week bringing the
nationwide total to at least 10 states
are moving fast to curb use of the
devices yesterday Rhode Island became
the latest state to ban the sale of
flavored e-cigarettes at least three
other states have announced a full or
partial ban on sales and this news comes
as the nation's largest east cigarette
company that's Jewell announced a new
CEO a former tobacco executive the
company faces growing questions about
its marketing amid soaring use of
e-cigarettes by teenagers big news in
the tobacco world Jul CEO Kevin Burns is
stepping down this looks like bad news
as the nation's vaping health crisis
explodes its largest cigarette company
is changing leadership Kevin Burns has
come under fire for his company's
handling of the vaping epidemic jool CEO
Kevin burns facing a steady rise in use
among teens youth usage is a serious
problem and we are committed to solving
it step down Wednesday he'll be replaced
by casey croft wait until now chief
growth officer at altria group one of
America's largest tobacco companies and
owner of a 35 percent stake in Joule
tested for toxicity last month we asked
burns about that investment did it hurt
your credibility to take billions of
dollars from Altria sellers of Marlboro
quintessential big tobacco company
certainly hurt us in the I would say in
the health and scientific community
certainly hurt us the FDA is accused
Joule of marketing to teens and making
unproven safety claims charges Jule
denies at the same time states are
cracking down on all forms of vaping
which has been linked to more than 500
illnesses and at least 10 deaths at a
hearing Wednesday lawmakers demanded
answers from the food and drug
administration how do we get to a point
where we've got now a widely-used
consumers a series of consumer products
that are getting 530 people sick in
retrospect the FDA should have acted
sooner we should have begun regulating
the devices sooner I think that what
this demonstrates is that
the e-cigarette market is basically
being handed to Big Tobacco dr. Michael
Siegel a physician and tobacco
researcher says Jules new leadership and
sweeping state restrictions on vape
products will do more harm than good I
think it's very unfortunate to go after
legal businesses that are selling
products that are helping so many
smokers to quit smoking and to stay off
cigarettes and jool also announced it
will suspend all US advertising and will
halt lobbying of the Trump
administration on a proposal to ban
flavored East cigarettes Jewell said in
a statement it will fully support and
comply with the final FDA policy or
Trump administration policy when it's
effective you said this yesterday Tony
the optics of putting a someone an
executive from Big Tobacco in Joule now
or not does that look good and at the
same time these state regulations are
putting small vape shops out of business
shops that have existed long before
there was a teen health crisis long
before there were these illnesses and
haven't been implicated so it is kind of
a hand over to Big Tobacco a new chapter
for Jewel's see how that works out